thrills and excitement on a roller
coaster at Vienna's pata amusement park
not too far away
dishes loop-the-loop on their way to the
tables of a roller coaster restaurants
thanks to a catapult mechanism and
gravity
he's been misstep I like it it's really
something new I've never seen anything
like it
that's definitely amusing and fun it's
something new a new generation of
restaurants so to speak can you fight
the fish I like the way the food comes
down like on a roller coaster
it just wishes down it's great the lids
are securely fastened so nothing spills
and in a global first the meals are sent
down the tracks to diners by robots in
older roller coaster restaurants that
task is still done by the human
employees in this new Vienna location
the robots even mix cocktails it's not
easy to teach an industrial robot that
kind of dexterity mom xenomorph I saw my
mom a lot I put the cocktails in jam
jars with lids that twist shut so we
have to tell the robot to open the jar
and then safely close it again so it
stays closed since it also has to shake
the jar to mix the cocktail it's
teaching at that movement of twisting
the lid shut took about a week I think I
never forget our guests place their
orders using a tablet computer the
burgers are especially popular
the kitchen staff needs to have special
training
you win our fresh coffee we want to cook
fresh food quickly we use the most
modern cooking technology like our ovens
which are all computer-controlled
and using them takes a lot of training
relative feel Coulomb as a normal cook
from a normal kitchen the technique is a
bit unfamiliar at first but once you get
used to it
you don't want to cook any other way
the first rollercoaster restaurant was
opened in Nuremberg in 2007 our location
in Hamburg followed three years later
guests in Abu Dhabi also appreciate the
high-tech ambiance back at the new
vienna location there's not much
opportunity for cultivated conversation
the music is loud and there's plenty of
entertainment including light shows
the robots dance for the guests too
it's a popular place for people to
celebrate their birthdays so birthday
songs are often heard over the
loudspeakers it's a surprise for 40 year
old magdalena jota
it's really different I've never had
this birthday serenade before despite
all the technology the roller-coaster
restaurant also still has human service
deaf they do more than just bus tables
yes cannot we servers explain to the
guests how the tablets work we show them
to their tables and we're always there
to answer questions just because there
are robots here doesn't mean we have
less or more to do yep meaning
automatically the owners of the roller
coaster restaurant are confident their
idea can be successful worldwide with
some entertainment our entertainment
concept which is unique in the world we
could expand very well into other
markets that are very technology
friendly like Asia or America said with
expansion in two weeks the next roller
coaster restaurant will open south of
Manchester England then in the middle of
the year a location is planned in Sochi
Russia the viennese location is putting
a new twist on the concept
you